to give opportunities for other people
of color to tell their stories
it means a great deal holding that door
open for others no matter who that is
holding that door open and really
lifting each other up that's what 2021
is to me yeah i just love to be a part
of projects that widen the lens you know
because once it's widened for us then
it's widened for you know asian for
you know mexican for everyone from the
record breakers
[Music]
to the hall of famer obviously a kid
from brooklyn you know so it's big for
us very exciting and shattering glass
ceilings black stars made history in
2021.
of course we gotta kick things off with
queen bee beyonce
the grammy goes to beyonce
i can't believe this
happened at the 63rd grammy awards she
broke allison krause's record for the
most grammy wins by a female artist ever
taking home her 28th award such a
magical night thank you so much and
let's not forget to mention this
barrier-breaking moment
[Music]
beyonce being the first black woman to
ever wear tiffany's iconic yellow
diamond
she's detail-oriented obviously as you
can see from her work and she's a
incredibly hard worker super talented
um very inspiring well speaking of jay-z
he made history too
and since i made it here i can make it
anywhere
becoming the most grammy-nominated
artist ever headed into the 64th annual
awards
i for not one second changing my course
now that's rock and roll that
achievement is the cherry on top of this
one
congrats us carter ghost rider
you paid the right price so we just made
your hits tighter
mr s carter became the first living solo
rapper to be inducted into the rock and
roll hall of fame he follows posthumous
honorees tupac and the notorious b.i.g
very important because you know
typically in these things there's no
sort of diversity
there's no one that represents the city
no one's from this city
victory never tasted so sweet
[Laughter]
rupaul sashayed his way into the history
books in september of 2021
claiming his 11th emmy as host of
rupaul's drag race making him the most
awarded black artist in emmy's history
little did they know that they would be
changing herstory
to this milestone the first rapper to
cover sports illustrated swimsuit
edition first rapper
on the cover
of si swim sports let me show you that
swimming sounds i know just i can't
believe it this is like an honor i've
always wanted to do this yeah and now i
have the opportunity to do it and so now
i feel like i'm opening the door
for other girls that look like me megan
appeared alongside another black change
maker lena bloom she's the first
transgender woman to grace the cover
ladybloom is also making history so i
just was like megan stallion like sell
all the coffees like i'm in it they're
going to see me they're going to see all
of us the mechanism oh my god
[Music]
black history even unfolded in
unexpected places like the 2021 academy
of country music awards as a woman as a
black woman
it is such an honor that people are
giving me this opportunity to be heard
and to
and to hopefully incite change four
black artists mickey guyton kane brown
jimmy allen and john legend all earned
nominations the most ever in acm history
congratulations jimmy i'm playing bro
stop playing
jimmy allen became the first black man
to win new male artist of the year and
kane brown became the first black solo
artist to win video of the year
representation is super important you
know because we it's kind of it's kind
of hard to tell a young black kid you
can be a country artist
when they don't see any
you know
so
it's cool to have that
now to a tv milestone
congratulations xavier
you
are the winner
of big brother
after 23 seasons of big brother xavier
prather became the first black person to
take home the cbs competition's
750 thousand dollar grand prize i came
to this game wanting to do anything and
everything i could to ensure that big
brother season 23 would be remembered
would be remembered as crowning the
first black winner in bb us history um
fortunately that was me thanks in large
part to the show's first ever all black
alliance the cookout you know what we're
talking about
the cookout
better talk money
then there's michaela cole the creator
writer and star of the hbo hit i may
destroy you surround yourself with
people who affirm you are you going to
miss me
who became the first black woman to win
an emmy for best limited series writing
it's inspired by
my um yes and some real life things that
happened to me
it's kind of amazing and weird and
overwhelming to
be here to have
all of those experiences
from the small screen to the big screen
this is where it all began
they stole your candy man
the 2021 remake of candyman was number
one at the box office on its opening
weekend it's really cool and exciting a
big part of that success goes to
director nia de costa she's the first
black female director to have a number
one opening
you know there's so many more black
filmmakers working and so many different
kinds of genres today and i'm really
excited about that and excited to be a
part of that
the world's moved on commander bond you
were double
so stay in your lane you get in my way i
will put a bullet in your knee another
black woman making moves on the big
screen is actress lashana lynch the very
first female and black double o agent in
the james bond franchise even being cast
in a bond movie isn't something that was
in my sphere you know i'm a manifesto
and i have like kind of tried to
manifest a lot in my career and this
just
passed me i didn't even realize all
right so exciting news and to our very
own agent of change a big congrats to
nichelle turner
nichelle turner is now the official
co-host of entertainment tonight it is
so well deserved she made history in
march when it was announced that she
would be the new co-host alongside kevin
fraser
i couldn't be happier you know how much
i love you and you know how much this
means thank you i'm like i'm not going
to cry i just want to say a quick thank
you mary hart it's nancy o'dell for
setting this table and i cannot even
believe this is happening
[Music]
[Music]
you